"THE FIVE" ."
WHO ARE THE LIBERALS BLAMING THE
BRETT KAVANAUGH CONFIRMATION ON?
THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE.
THOSE FOUNDERS JUST AREN’T AS
SMART AS ROB REINER?
HOW IS IT THAT STATES EACH HAVE
TWO SENATORS?
NEW YORK AND CALIFORNIA SHOULD
HAVE 25 EACH AND YOU ARE HOME,
ZILCH.
FAILING THAT, THERE’S ALWAYS
IMPEACHMENT.
>> DO YOU RULE OUT THIS IDEA OF
IMPEACHING KAVANAUGH?
>> THIS IMPEACHMENT THING, I AM
FOCUSED ON THE HERE AND NOW.
>> YOU WON’T RULE OUT
IMPEACHMENT.
>> I AM MUCH MORE FOCUSED ON
WHAT WE NEED TO DO WHICH IS GET
CONTROL.
>> Greg: WHY NOT JUST REAL --
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" CLAIMING
KAVANAUGH ON GENDER TRADERS.
WHITE WOMEN BENEFIT FROM
PATRIARCHY BY TRADING ON THEIR
WHITENESS TO MONOPOLIZE
RESOURCES FOR MUTUAL GAIN.
WHO TALKS LIKE THAT HAS A JOB?
THE LEFT DEVOURS ITS OWN AS RAGE
BOTS.
YET AS THEY SHARPEN THE
PITCHFORKS, DEMOCRATS HAVEN’T
DISOWNED AVENATTI WHO USE WOMEN
AS STEPPING-STONES.
IT SEEMS WE ARE AT AN IMPASSE
WHICH IS FRENCH FOR NOWHERE
GOOD.
ONE PARTY SAYS HE MUCH BELIEVE
ALL ALLEGATIONS AND THE OTHER
SAYS YOU MUST PRESUME INNOCENCE.
ON ONE SIDE ARE THESE WOMEN AND
ON THE OTHER SIDE THIS GAME.
WHAT IS THE SOLUTION?
IT IS SIMPLE.
IF DEMOCRATS PREFER BELIEF OVER
DUE PROCESS, PUT A RING ON EDGE.
FROM HERE AND DEMOCRATS SHOULD
BELIEVE ANY ALLEGATION AGAINST
THEMSELVES BECAUSE 50% OF
BELIEVING IS BETTER THAN NONE.
NO PROCESS, JUST PUNISHMENT.
THE REST OF US IDIOTS WILL RELY
ON STUPID STUFF LIKE EVIDENCE
AND DUE PROCESS.
MAKE SENSE, DEMOCRATS?
THE, THE PARTY OF PITCHFORKS.
MAYBE THEN WE’LL WILL BELIEVE
IT’S NOT JUST POLITICS.
DAGAN, WELCOME TO THE SHOW.
WE SHOULD HAVE --
>> J: THIS IS WHY THEY TALK
ABOUT IMPEACHMENT.
THEIR AGENDA IS ANTI-TRUMP OR
ANTIWOMAN.
WHAT KIND OF SENATOR IS MAZIE
HIRONO TO LET THE ANCHORMAN
CULTURE LIKE THAT.
>> Greg: HE WAS MAN-SPLAINING.
>> THE DEMOCRATS ALWAYS
OVERSTEPPED.
WHAT THEY HAVE DONE HERE IS IT
STRIKES EVEN MORE CLOSELY INTO
THE CORE OF AMERICAN VALUES
BECAUSE DUE PROCESS HAS BEEN
THROWN OUT.
THE IDEA OF FAIRNESS IN THIS
COUNTRY HAS BEEN TRAMPLED ON AND
IF YOU ARE A MAN, YOU ARE GUILTY
IF YOU ARE A MAN, YOU ARE GUILTYUNTIL PROVEN INNOCENT AND IF YOU
UNTIL PROVEN INNOCENT AND IF YOU
ARE A WOMAN, YOU JUST BETTER
SHUT UP AND ACT AS    AS A MONOL
SHUT UP AND ACT AS    AS A MONOT
SHUT UP AND ACT AS    AS A MONOI
SHUT UP AND ACT AS    AS A MONOC
GROUP AND FOLLOW-UP THE
DEMOCRATS TELL YOU.
PEOPLE ARE REJECTING THAT ACROSS
THE BOARD.
>> Greg: JUAN, YOU LOOK AT
NORTH DAKOTA AND SAY WHY DO THEY
HAVE TWO SENATORS?
YOU HAVE SAID THAT TO ME.
I THINK IT’S A DIRECT QUOTE.
YOU THINK THIS IS FUNDAMENTALLY
UNFAIR, RIGHT?
THAT EACH STATE HAS TWO SENATORS
WHEN THEY ARE LESS POPULATED.
>> Juan: I LIKE IT.
WHAT I DON’T LIKE AND I THINK
WHAT I HAVE SAID HE WAS 18% OF
THE COUNTRY IS REPRESENTED BY
THE MAJORITY OF THE SENATE.
IN OTHER WORDS, 82% OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE NOT
REPRESENTED BY THE MAJORITY.
I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE FEEL
THIS BOILS DOWN TO TEAR ANY.
THAT WAS THE WORD YOU WERE
SIDING BEFORE.
IN THIS CASE, THE PEOPLE WHO
MOST ENJOY TALK OF IMPEACHMENT
ARE REPUBLICANS BECAUSE IT STIRS
UP THEIR BASE.
THEY ARE ALWAYS TALKING ABOUT
IT.
LOOK AT THE LEADERSHIP ON THE
DEMOCRATIC SIDE, SCHUMER AND
PELOSI, THEY DON’T TALK ABOUT
IT.
THERE ARE SOME PEOPLE, THE LEFT
FLANK OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
I AM TALKING ABOUT ESPECIALLY
NEWLY ELECTED -- THEY HAVEN’T
QUITE BEEN ELECTED YET BUT WHEN
THERE’S ON THE DEMOCRATIC SIDE
LIKE ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ,
LISA PRESLEY, UP IN
MASSACHUSETTS.
THEY SAY LISTEN, IT’S TIME FOR
THE DEMOCRATS TO BE A STRONG, AS
CONSISTENT, AS BULLISH AS YOU
SAW FROM MITCH MCCONNELL WHEN HE
RAN OVER EVERYBODY, HELD THE
SENATE SEAT -- SORRY
SUPREME COURT SEAT OPEN.
>> Greg: THAT IS THE NEXT
BLOCK.
A >> Juan: IF REPUBLICANS PLAY
HARDBALL, THEY SAY HEY,
DEMOCRATS, STOP BEING SO
SQUISHY.
>> Greg: YOU END UP WITH A
AVENATTI WHO GOES TOO FAR AND
DANA I BET YOU HAVE A GOOD POINT
ABOUT WHY THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE
IS IMPORTANT.
IT’S A CLASSIC ARGUMENT.
THEY WANT TO RELY ON A
METROPOLITAN CANDIDATE AT THE
EXPENSE OF SMALL TOWN RURAL
AREAS, WHERE YOU ARE FROM.
>> Dana: WYOMING HAS TWO
SENATORS AND ONE REPRESENTATIVE
SO I HAVE DONE A LITTLE BIT OF
WORK ON THIS BECAUSE I KEEP
SEEING IT POP UP OVER AND OVER
AGAIN.
I NOTICED IT IN THOUSAND ZERO,
BUSH V GORE.
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ TWEETED
THIS WEEKEND THAT THE ELECTORAL
COLLEGE IS RACIST.
SHE SUGGESTED THE FOUNDING
FATHERS WANTED TO PROTECT
SLAVERY AND THAT’S WHY THEY CAME
UP WITH THE IDEA OF THE
ELECTORAL COLLEGE.
THAT’S NOT TRUE.
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE OF THAT AT
ALL.
ABRAHAM LINCOLN, WHO WAS
PRESIDENT THAT ENDED SLAVERY, HE
DID NOT WIN THE POPULAR VOTE.
HE GOT 37% BUT HE WON IN THE
ELECTORAL COLLEGE.
THANK GOODNESS FOR THE ELECTORAL
COLLEGE THAT HELPED END SLAVERY.
>> Greg: EXCELLENCE.
>> Jesse: IF YOU’RE GOING TO
ELIMINATE EVERY INSTITUTION THAT
HAD ITS ROOTS IN SLAVERY, YOU
HAVE TO ELIMINATE THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
LOOK AT THE HISTORY OVER THERE
ON YOUR SIDE, JUAN.
NOT TOO GOOD.
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY ENDED
SLAVERY.
>> Greg: WE SHOULD MOVE ON
FROM THAT.
>> Dana: IT’S TRUE THAT A LOT
OF PEOPLE ARE MOVING TO THE
COAST, CALIFORNIA, FLORIDA,
TEXAS, NEW YORK, THOSE ARE BIG
STATES.
IT COULD CHANGE.
NEW YORK IS SEEING POPULATIONS
LEAVE IN DROVES BECAUSE OF
TAXES.
>> Jesse: THESE THINGS HAVE A
WAY OF BALANCING OUT.
IF YOU SAY THAT THE SENATE IS
TYRANNY, YOU HAVE THE HOUSE.
CHECKS AND BALANCES, THE
WHITE HOUSE, SUPREME COURT,
OTHER THINGS.
JUAN IS SAYING THAT THE
REPUBLICANS RAMMED IT HOME SO
HARD ON THE DEMOCRATS WERE SOFT.
I THINK THIS IS THE FIRST TIME
REPUBLICANS SHOWED UP TO A
GUNFIGHT WITH A GUN INSTEAD OF A
KNIFE.
VOTERS ARE GOING TO REWARD THEM
FOR THAT.
THE IMPEACHMENT THING, I
COMPLETELY AGREE WITH YOU.
IT’S GOING TO FIRE UP THE
REPUBLICAN BASE AND THE
DEMOCRATS LOOK CRAZY AND
EXTREME.
AFTER A WHILE, THE VOTERS ARE
GOING TO SAY HEALTH CARE,
EDUCATION COSTS, WAGES.
WHAT IS AN IMPEACHMENT FIGHT
OVER A SUPREME COURT JUSTICE DO
FOR ME AT ALL.
I THINK THE DEMOCRATS ARE GOING
TO GET WAY CAUGHT OUT THERE NOT
REALLY FOCUSED ON WHAT THE
ACTUAL PEOPLE IN THIS COUNTRY
THINK.
THE OTHER THING IS THAT
DEMOCRATS AND THE MEDIA LOOKED
SO ANGRY AND HATEFUL AND
DESPERATE AND WERE FLOUTING ALL
THE RULES.
THE VOTERS IN AMERICA I BELIEVE
ARE GOING TO LOOK AND SAY IF THE
DEMOCRATS GET POWER BACK AFTER
THE MIDTERMS, THEY ARE GOING TO
GO NUTS WITH IT.
WE HAVE SEEN HOW DANGEROUS THEY
CAN BE OUT OF POWER.
>> Juan: SUPREME COURT
NOMINATIONS MEAN SOMETHING.
THEY MEAN SOMETHING IN POLITICAL
TERMS.
I DON’T THINK THERE’S ANY DOUBT
PEOPLE THINK AS OF TODAY WITH
KAVANAUGH ON THE COURT, IF YOU
LOOK AT ABORTION RIGHTS,
GUN-CONTROL, VOTER RIGHTS IN THE
COUNTRY.
THERE IS A REPUBLICAN MAJORITY,
VERY CONSERVATIVE ON ALL THOSE
ISSUES.
MUCH MORE OPEN TO PUTTING, IN
THE CASE OF ABORTION, LIMITS AND
IN THE CASE OF VOTING RIGHTS,
LIMITS.
IMMIGRATION.
WE ARE GOING TO RUBBER-STAMP ANY
CONSERVATIVE --
>> Dagen: MAYBE NOW THE
DEMOCRATS HAVE TO ELECT PEOPLE
TO LEGISLATE AND PASS LAWS
RATHER THAN USING OUR JUDICIAL
SYSTEM TO DO IT.
>> Juan: I DON’T THINK THAT’S
THE ISSUE.
>> Dagen: NOW THAT YOU HAVE A
COURT THAT’S CONSERVATIVE,
FOCUSED ON THE ACTUAL
CONSTITUTION RATHER THAN MAKING
LAWS TO THE COURT SYSTEM AND
JUDICIAL.
>> Juan: THEY HAD TO AMEND THE
CONSTITUTION AND VIEW IT NOT AS
STRICT CONSTRUCTIONIST.
>> Dagen: I AM --
>> Greg: DO YOU LIKE MY IDEA
THAT THE DEMOCRATS SHOULD PUT
THEIR MONEY WHERE THEIR MOUTH IS
AND SUSPEND DUE PROCESS FOR
DEMOCRATS?
>> Juan: THIS IS SILLY.
I CAN SEE THAT IT DELIGHTS YOU.
>> Greg: I THINK IT IS GENIUS.
>> Juan: THIS GUY HAD HIS LIFE
ON THE LINE?
THIS WAS NOT ABOUT DUE PROCESS.
THIS WAS ABOUT A TEST OF
CHARACTER.
>> Dana: TALK ABOUT A TEST OF
>> Jesse: CHARACTER
ASSASSINATION.
>> Dana: DEMOCRATS SAY THEY
WANT TO BE MORE CYNICAL LIKE THE
REPUBLICANS, I THINK THIS PAST
FEW WEEKS HAS SHOWN THEM TO BE
THE MOST CYNICAL, AND EXTREME OF
WANTING TO FIGURE OUT A WAY TO
CHANGE THE SYSTEM IN ORDER TO
WIN.
THEY WANT TO CHANGE THE